to your colleagues and your patients
know about your films me yes you can
google anyone these days and how do you
tell them they're talking well you know
my colleagues know about it and I think
it's really cool Dale's there all's
asking and they're very excited for me
it's pretty interesting because um you
know as as physicians we have our
interests I mean my colleagues they they
like to golf they like to go on think
i'd like to go on these great and
interesting trips and vacations I spent
all my time focusing on filmmaking so
it's a little I have different I get
debuted as a hobby i Doan its deadly not
a hobby it's it's a passion it's a it's
a career it's a profession but they're
very enthralled by very you know they
they're they're actually very supportive
it's pretty interesting I I thought it'd
be the complete opposite but i but i had
already established a reputation amongst
them for being very dedicated and very
trustworthy with patients that we share
so it wasn't i didn't come across as
being flaky like oh here's a doctor's
you know auditioning for old it didn't
it didn't come out like that and gross
my patients I don't tell them because i
have a very you know when I'm when I'm
in the clinic I'm doctors to do and I'm
focused on you it's never about me I'm
just absolutely focused on you so I
don't mention it I don't bring it up if
somebody alludes to it i just kind of go
around it because you know your time in
my clinic is for you and that's it and
it has nothing to do with me other than
me trying to help you get to a healthy
state so i have a very clear cut line
even my whole staff don't discuss it
with them simple as that if they ask
about it I just keep silent which I just
kind of move around it because that's
you know hey I want them geared towards
patient care and then on this side you
know yeah that's where I got that's
where I got my other team you know like
Hiram and Chris and Monica and then
they're focused here and so it's so cool
you